>> Tucker: WE BRING YOU ANOTHER
INSTALLMENT IN OUR ONGOING
DEVELOPMENT OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE LONG DISSENT FROM A MIDDLE
CLASS UTOPIA TO THE KIND OF
PLACE THAT DONALD TRUMP WON'T
WANT IMMIGRATION FROM.
THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES ARE KNOWN
FOR ELECTION FRAUD.
CALIFORNIA'S DMV JUST ADMITTED
TO ACCIDENTALLY REGISTERING MORE
THAN 1,500 NONCITIZENS TO VOTE.
LOS ANGELES MEANWHILE,
LOS ANGELES IS GRAPPLING WITH
TYPHUS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO, AN APP CALLED
SNAP CRAP JUST HELPED RESIDENTS
REPORT LOCAL WASTE ON THE
SIDEWALK TO THE GOVERNMENT.
VICTOR HANSON IS A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN.
HIS FAMILY HAS BEEN THERE FOR
SIX GENERATIONS IN THE SAME
HOUSE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU ON THE SET.
SO I JUST -- LET'S STAND BACK
REALLY QUICKLY AND ASK THE
OBVIOUS QUESTION.
HOW DID THE GREATEST STATE GO TO
WHAT IT IS NOW?
>> A PERFECT STORM.
WE HAD $3 TRILLION CAP IN FOR
CAPITOLIZATION OF FACEBOOK AND
GOOGLE.
CONVINCED MILLIONS WHERE THE
MONEY WAS CONCENTRATED THAT THEY
WERE NOT SUBJECT TO THEIR OWN
IDEOLOGY.
THEY COULD AFFORD THE DREAM AND
HAVE ALL OF THESE RESTRICTIONS,
GREATER REGULATIONS, GREEN
UTOPIAN IDEAS THAT WOULD AFFECT
OTHER PEOPLE MOSTLY IN THE
INTERIOR BUT NOT ALWAYS.
HOUSING WENT UP BECAUSE OF THE
REGULATIONS.
SMALL BUSINESSES FLED.
TAXES.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST BASKET OF
GASOLINE SALES AND INCOME TAXES
IN THE NINE STATES.
>> THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THE TAXES IN SAUDI ARABIA ARE
LOW BECAUSE THEY HAVE LIKE THE
BAY AREA --
>> THERE'S OTHER ELEMENTS TO
THIS DISASTER.
WE HAD 10 TO 15 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT CAME ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WITHOUT LEGALITY, WITHOUT
ENGLISH OR A DIPLOMA.
SO ALL OF A SUDDEN CALIFORNIA
BECAME A MEDIEVAL SOCIETY.
IT'S LIKE A KEEP.
THE COASTAL STRIP IS THE CASTLE
KEEP WHERE THE ELITE LIVE AND
EVERYBODY ELSE SERVES THEM.
THE MIDDLE CLASS HAS FLED.
WE HAVE A THIRD OF WELFARE
RECIPIENTS.
20% OF THE STATE IS BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE.
WHEN YOU GET SCHOOLS 46th IN THE
NATION AND INFRASTRUCTURE RAINED
49th.
THANK GOT FOR MISSISSIPPI.
>> Tucker: ARKANSAS USED TO SAY
THAT.
NOW IT'S CALIFORNIA.
SO THE REST OF THE VIEWERS THAT
DON'T LIVE IN CALIFORNIA, WHAT
DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH US?
SHOULD WE BE WORRIED ABOUT THIS?
>> YES.
CALIFORNIA GAVE US PETE WILSON,
REAGAN.
IT FLIPPED TO A ONE-PARTY STATE.
THAT WAS THIS WEIRD NEW
COMBINATION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
IT'S A PYRAMIDAL SOCIETY.
AMERICA'S WEALTHY PEOPLE ARE
LEFT WING NOW.
THEY'RE ULTRA WEALTHY AND THEY
HAVE A SUBSIDIZED POOR ON THE
BOTTOM.
THAT WAS THE PARADIGM THAT
OVERREGULATED, OVERTAXED AND
SENT PEOPLE OUT OF THE STATE.
>> Tucker: THERE'S A QUESTION
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
LET'S SAY YOU'RE THE 41-YEAR-OLD
MULTIBILLIONAIRE THAT OWNS
TWITTER.
TEN MINUTES AWAY PEOPLE ARE
DYING OF ODs ON THE SIDEWALK.
>> BECAUSE YOU FEEL GUILTY ABOUT
YOUR WEALTH.
SO IN THE ABSTRACT, YOU CAN
AFFORD TO BE LEFT WING AND HELP
THE POOR WHILE YOUR GETS GOO  GO
TO SACRED WALL.
WALLS DON'T WORK ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER BUT THEY WORK AND YOUR
STATE.
SO YOU CAN NAVIGATE ABOUT THE
ROBERT MUELLERIFICATIONS OF YOUR
OWN IDEOLOGY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
>> Tucker: YOU'D THINK THEY WANT
TO HELP THE PEOPLE OUT THEIR
DOOR.
>> YES.
GO TO REDWOOD CITY.
AT THIS TIME SERVICE AREA FOR
SILICON VALLEY.
MEXICAN FAMILIES HAVE SIX AND
SEVEN FAMILIES IN A HOUSE.
THEY'RE NOT LIBERAL AT ALL.
>> Tucker: THEY'RE NOT.
>> THEY RUINED THE STATE.